thinking that we're going to be hearing
from the prime minister who will be
telling us about it
in more detail as joe was just saying it
is a foreign vaccine at this stage
but thomas we are developing a british
one as well and it's not too far behind
two british ones one is
from oxford and that is also being
considered
thomas to you uh momentarily but let's
hear from downing street
of the medicines and healthcare products
regulatory agency
the uk's independent regulator for
medicines
vaccines and medical devices
may i first introduce the colleagues who
are with me this morning
on my left is professor sir munir per
mohammed
professor of medicine at liverpool
university
and chair of the chm's expert working
group
on covid 19 vaccines that's the
commission
on human medicines the government's
independent
advisory body and samanier will provide
more detail
on his work shortly on my right
is professor wei shen lim professor of
respiratory medicine at nottingham
university
and chair of the joint committee on
vaccination and immunization
subgroup which has been preparing advice
on covert 19 vaccines
this briefing has been called to
announce
that the medicines and healthcare
products regulatory agency
has this week recommended to the uk
government
on the basis of the advice of the
commission on human medicines
that it should agree to the approval for
use
of the covid19 vaccine developed by
pfizer biontech together with the
conditions
for its supply and use
the mhra's recommendation has been
reached
following an extremely thorough and
scientifically rigorous review
of all the evidence of safety
of effectiveness and of quality of the
pfizer biontech
vaccine the uk government has now
accepted
this advice and has made the decision to
approve the vaccine for use
with some conditions in adults age 16
and over the safety of the public
will always come first
and i emphasize again that this
recommendation has only been given
by the mhra following the most rigorous
scientific assessment of every piece of
data
so that it meets the required strict
standards
of safety of effectiveness and of
quality
we have two or three slides this morning
to help
our discussion get moving
and in the first one you can see
that unlike the usual pattern of
clinical trials
which are done one after another the
development of this vaccine has been
adapted
so the trials are overlapping and the
next one can start
before a particular phase has finished
and in this way we have been able to
progress development
in the shortest time possible
on the next slide you can see how the
mhra
has worked and i would like to tell you
a little more about this
just now it's been done
using a process known as a rolling
review
a rolling review can be used to complete
the assessment
of a promising medicine or a vaccine in
a situation
where time is of the essence in the
shortest time possible
but and this is a very important point
indeed
that doesn't mean that any corners have
been cut
none at all so looking for the top
downwards the expert working group
started in the middle of the year
to look at how safety surveillance would
be in place
to give us the highest possible level of
assurance
of the safety of the covid 19 vaccine
and that preparation and planning has
been done with meticulous care
similarly our national institute for
biological
standards and control have been working
independently
on testing batch by batch
the quality of the vaccine then in
october
the pre-clinical analysis data became
available
that's the third bar down followed by
the interim analysis
on the 10th of november the quality
analysis
came very shortly after that and most
recently
the batch testing has begun with a final
analysis
at the very end of the process so it's
very
clear that separate teams have been
working in parallel
to deliver the most rigorous review of
this vaccine
no corners have been cut our expert
scientists and clinicians have worked
round the clock
carefully methodically pouring over
tables
and analyses and graphs on every single
piece of data
hundreds over a thousand pages of data
and absolutely critically analyzing the
pre-clinical evidence
the clinical trials the manufacturing
and quality controls
and then down to the final sampling
we've also reviewed and agreed the
prescribing information
so that the public and healthcare
professionals are very clear
and can be very confident that the
vaccine is being reused in the correct
way
understanding what's involved and going
forward from today
our national institute for biological
standards and control
will be independently laboratory testing
so that every single
vaccine that goes out meets the same
high standards
of safety and quality
and we've benefited from a further
safety step too
following our thorough review of the
data at the mhra
we have sought the advice of the
government's independent body
the commission on human medicines and
i'd now like to turn to professor sir
munir
to explain the pivotal part its
independent members have played
in critically assessing every piece of
evidence
munir thank you very much june so i
chaired
the chm's expert working group
and first of all i'd like to thank the
members of the expert working group who
worked with me tirelessly with over 40
hours
of face-to-face on zoom at least
committee work
and additional reading time we made
recommendations to the commission
on new medicines uh which and then
undertook an independent review and the
commission in medicines
is chaired by professor stuart ralston
we had a wide variety of experts
on both groups including people who are
experts in viral diseases immunologists
epidemiologists who look at disease
patterns clinical pharmacologists and
toxicologists who are experts in various
aspects of medicines
we looked at all sorts of data which is
available to us
including raw data unprecedented access
to raw data
and this allowed us to look at the
overall
risk benefit analysis we look at risk
benefit analysis for every compound that
comes through in terms of licensing
and we use the same stringent standards
to be able to
look at the risk benefit of this
particular vaccine
we looked at laboratory data we looked
at
the manufacturing processes and the
quality data
as well as the clinical trial data
from this we came to the conclusion that
those overwhelming a benefit
for this particular vaccine and
therefore recommended to the mhra
that its use should be authorized
i just want to say a few things about
the effectiveness
of this vaccine the data showed that
this vaccine is 95
effective it is effective in all the
groups that were given
the vaccine within the trial
irrespective of age
sex race or country that they lived in
we've also looked at the safety of this
the safety of the
vaccine is similar to other vaccines and
most of the
side effects are very mild and usually
last for
a day or so we've been very careful to
look at the quality
of the vaccine particularly given the
need for
storing the vaccine at ultra low
temperatures
and we were
we had uh visits from uh nhs colleagues
to tell us what the deployment
strategies were
and we were able to advise them as well
on the uh stability issues that may
be important for uh deployment it's
important to note that
what we have got is data relating to the
vaccine
up to this point it is important that we
undertake surveillance
following the use of vaccines in the
population
and we were very keen to recommend
that the mhra undertakes active
surveillance of the vaccine after it is
used
and this includes the use of yellow
cards as well as a
special active monitoring program which
we will be inviting people to join
the committee also considered that no
specific precautions were required
on administration of this vaccine in
people who already have had
coveted 19 and no testing is required
before receiving the vaccine thank you
june thank you so munir
now i'll turn to professor lim weishan
to tell us
about the work of the joint committee on
vaccination
and immunisation thank you june
the joint committee on vaccination and
immunization
is an independent scientific advisory
body
we advise the secretary of state on the
provision
of vaccination and immunization services
as a committee we've been meeting
regularly over the last few months
we've done that to appraise new and
emerging scientific evidence related to
our role
on the slide you will see the types of
information
that we've been assessing these include
data on vaccine safety and efficacy but
also how
copenhagen has impacted the uk this
includes
impacts of covert 19 in care homes on
people from different
different ethnic groups as well as
people in different occupations
the data have come from primary care
from public health england
and from hospitals we've also looked at
mathematical
models that helped us to understand how
different vaccine strategies
might be used the uk is fortunate in
that we have one
of the best immunization programs in the
world
every year through the infant's
childhood and adult vaccination programs
millions of us are protected from
serious disease
all of that expertise also informs
jcbi's decision making
for the first phase of the pandemic and
its vaccination program
we are suggesting that vaccines
are offered in order to protect people
who are most at risk
of dying from covet 19 as well as to
protect
health and social care services because
by doing so
we also protect lives the advice is
divided
into two main parts the first
is to offer vaccination according to the
estimated risk of dying from covet 19.
the risk of dying from covet 19 is very
strongly associated with age
age is by far the single most important
factor
in terms of risk from corvette 19.
the second strand to the advice is
regarding implementation of the
vaccination program
and we advise that due attention is paid
locally
to mitigating health inequalities i'll
say more of that in a moment
on the next slide you will see
the prioritization order in terms of the
offer of vaccination
residents in care homes for older adults
and care home workers
are the highest priority following that
are those 80 years of age and above
alongside front line healthcare and
social care workers
then come those 75 years of age and
above
followed by those 70 years of age and
above
alongside people who are clinically
extremely vulnerable
because of specific health conditions
they're followed by people who are aged
65 years and above
and then individuals who are aged 16 to
64 years
with underlying health conditions that
also put them at risk at covet 19
but where those conditions are not
already represented
in the conditions putting somebody at
clinically extremely vulnerable risk
the prioritization order then continues
down the age groups
until all those aged 50 years and above
are included this is phase one
of the program in phase one
we hope that 90 to 99 percent of people
who are at risk of dying from covet 19
will be included or covered
the next part of the advice relates to
implementation of the program we advise
that
local nhs providers local public health
teams
and local leaders work together to
address
community needs and local
needs we suggest
that community teams work together to
mitigate against health inequalities
that might occur in relation to
ethnicity
deprivation or access to health care
we also recognize that there may be
operational reasons
why the prioritization needs to be more
flexible
this may relate to vaccine
characteristics or vaccine supply
or exceptional personal circumstances
overall we have good news today we have
a vaccine
that is acceptably safe and effective
good vaccine uptake will save lives
thank you thank you professor lin
let's now turn to questions from the
media
and our first question comes from fergus
walsh of the bbc
right thanks very much um question for
uh dr june rain um how can
can you reassure the public that
they can have absolute confidence in
this vaccine given
how quickly you've approved it and for
professor
weishen lim can you just sum up for me
the reasoning behind your list of
priorities
about who gets the vaccine first
thank you a really important point
relates to the thorough work
scientifically rigorous
methodologically sound that the agency
has done
and the way of working in a rolling
review
ensures that our teams of clinicians and
scientists
are working in parallel to complete
all the work according to strict
guidelines
on safety effectiveness and quality
is complete this vaccine has only been
approved
because those strict tests have been
done and complied with
and everyone can be absolutely confident
that no corners whatsoever have been cut
perhaps if i could think of an
acknowledge analogy if you're climbing a
mountain
you prepare and prepare we started that
in june by the time the interim results
became available
on the 10th of november we were at base
camp
and then when we got the final analysis
we were ready for that last sprint
that takes us to today and that is the
exemplary nature
of the work that's been done and the
public
deserve nothing less i'll hand to
professor lim now
thank you so in relation to the offer of
vaccination
prioritization was based on the
risk of dying from covet 19
and in order to protect the most
vulnerable
we have prioritized the most vulnerable
individuals first
the other element is protection of the
nhs the health and social care system
because by protecting the nhs we also
protect lives
thank you we now turn to victoria
mcdonald from channel 4
good morning good morning thank you very
much
can you explain for me why the mhra
has been able to authorize this vaccine
so much faster than the european
medicines
agency and the food and drug
administration is there any difference
in the levels of
evidence that was submitted or the
checks required
and secondly how long is the lag or is
there a lag between being given the
vaccine and for it to become
effective thank you i'll take the first
question
and then turn to summoner the way in
which the mhra
has worked is equivalent to all
international standards
we are well aware of our national
situation
and therefore we have mounted teams
built our capability
and worked in parallel and i want to
thank the colleagues who've worked
day and night weekends to enable us to
come to this position
the public can be absolutely confident
that the standards we have worked to
are equivalent to those around the world
so munir the the vaccine requires two
doses
uh 21 days apart and from the data
that's been presented to us
you uh people will be immune seven days
after the second dose
a partial immunity does occur after the
first dose
and we can see some protection occurring
after day 12
of the first dose but the best immunity
is
seven days after the second dose
there will of course be longer-term
follow-up to provide
further reassurance from the data the
robust data we already have
our next question comes from emily
morgan
of itv good morning
hello good morning my first question is
to you dr
rayne um this is a pretty historic
moment you've approved this vaccine in
record time
i just wondered how much of a momentous
moment
this is for you and indeed for science
and then a question to professor
lim this is on the priority list can you
confirm
that care home residents will indeed
still be the first to receive this
vaccine given how unstable it is and
tricky to move
to uh care homes and care home residents
or indeed
will nhs staff actually in fact be
the first to receive it thank you i'll
take the first question if i may
the reason we're here today is the
brilliance of science
and also the altruism of all those
people who have
enlisted in clinical trials to give us
the tremendously robust data
we have today and thirdly it's due to
the
agility commitment and extremely high
scientific standards
of all the staff at the mhra who've
worked on this
and the privilege of having an expert
advisory outreach
our commission on human medicines and
its expert group chaired by sirmener
so it is the culmination of all these
things that the uk is able to bring
together and to look always to the
public for whom this is for
professor lim thank you
the jcbs advice is aimed at
maximizing benefit from vaccines
and therefore it's aimed at the most
vulnerable people
which are people in care homes
whether or not the vaccine itself can be
delivered to care homes is obviously an
important point and there will be some
flexibility in terms of
operational constraints the jcbi's
advice is that every effort should be
made
to supply vaccine and offer vaccinations
to care home residents whether or not
that is
actually doable is dependent on
deployment and implementation
thank you i wonder if someone here you
would like to add
because clearly while the responsibility
of the mhra relates to the standards of
science we also look at it in the
context of the real world
which is what professor lim has
described so munir
yeah so we did obviously look at the
stability of the vaccine as you said it
is
stored at -70 degrees but
we were able to look at stability data
and there's stability data showing that
it is stable for a short period of time
at two to eight degrees
which allows it to be transported to the
relevant vaccination sites
thank you let's now turn to the next
question which comes from gordon raynor
of the daily telegraph
thank you can i ask um have you
uh identified when do you know when the
first vaccine will be
will be delivered which day we're gonna
we can expect that have you identified
the the first person who's going to get
it
and if not how are you going to decide
who that person will be
will the highest risk tears be given
priority
so the the tier three areas with the
highest uh
incidents and also can ask whether you
know whether
economic decisions have been factored in
um i.e when you get down
the list of priorities will people who
can't work from home
get the vaccine before people who can
work from home
these are helpful points that everyone
wants to know and i know my colleagues
in the department of health and social
care are working
again tirelessly to make sure that the
first vaccine will be delivered
as soon as all the checks are completed
i can speak for the national institute
for biological standards and control
who are ready to complete their checks
on the first
batch so everything is being looked at
24 7 to enable this important public
health step
to be put in place as soon as possible
not a minute wasted
dr lynn would you like to talk a bit
more about your perspective on this
as far as i understand the nhs is
working hard to deliver the vaccines
as soon as possible but that is not
within the remits of jcbi to
impose any time limits on vaccine
delivery
bear in mind too that many thousands
have already had the vaccine
as part of clinical trials so there is a
continuum here and our knowledge of
benefits
increases over time so perhaps it will
seem to be a historic moment when the
first person
after the approval of supply has their
vaccine
but semineer we see this very much as a
an ongoing process absolutely so it is
very much ongoing process with regard to
this vaccine
and and future vaccines coming through
in order to be able to
make sure the relevant people in the jci
list
are given the vaccine in the priority
order that
that was shown this is a good point for
me to
stress that we will be inviting members
of the public to join
us in an active monitoring program and
many will get a letter it'll be by
random allocation
inviting them to join this so please
help
us to continue to build that body of
knowledge
about this important vaccine
can i just could i just ask the point
about whether the highest risk tears are
the ones which will get it first
professor lim that is the intention of
the
prioritization order is that the most
vulnerable people are offered the
vaccination
first
thank you
sorry in tier three
you mean regional tiers um
we we've uh our prizes prioritization
order
is not dependent on which tier somebody
is in
it is a national prioritization order
thank you that's very clear let's turn
to the next question
andy woodcock from the independent good
morning
good morning um a couple of things we
appear to be getting
uh authorization of this vaccine ahead
of um
our friends in europe i was just
wondering does the fact that the
uk is no longer part of the eu did that
make any difference to the speed with
which you're able to
um complete your authorisation and
secondly
as i understand it the vaccine which
you've ordered which you've authorized
we don't we haven't ordered sufficient
quantities to cover the whole of the
population
i was wondering do we have enough of
this vaccine to get through all of the
priority groups which you listed
earlier on or would we be dependent on
waiting for further vaccines to be
authorized
in order to get to the position where
the whole country can can
be safe from this disease
we have been able to authorize the
supply of this vaccine
using provisions under european law
which exist
until the 1st of january so
our speed or our progress has been
totally dependent
on the availability of data in our
rolling review
and the rigorous assessment and
independent advice we have
received so i hope that clarifies the
point about the
european relationship let's turn
to professor lim around availability
is there anything you'd like to add on
this yes so it's a very good question
about vaccine supply and availability
the whole reason why a priority listing
is required is because we expect during
a pandemic
that vaccine supply will be limited in
the first instance
and so vaccine should be offered in the
first instance to the most vulnerable
moving down the priority list we will
need as many vaccines as we
can get not just in the uk but globally
and this includes more than one vaccine
type in order to reach
all the people who are at risk from
covet 19. so this is the start of a
program
and not the end of a program
and we are absolutely in liaison with
colleagues in the department of health
and social care
in terms of all the evidence that we
have to enable them to do their job
to make sure availability is assured
let's now turn to the next question from
chris mussen
of scottish sun good morning good
morning everybody
um can i just check what will your
message be your simple message to people
who are skeptical about vaccine safety
particularly in light of some of the
anti-vaxx misinformation that we're
seeing spreading on social media
and can i check also are you you're
obviously going through a similar
process with other
prospective vaccines can you just
summarize which ones
and what are the time scale variables
the expected time scales for approval on
those other vaccines
thank you the public
can be absolutely confident that every
rigorous check has been done
to reach the judgment that we reached
that the benefits
far outweigh any risk that the safety of
the vaccine has been scrutinized
independently by our commission on human
medicines
and no stone has been left unturned so
absolute confidence
in the safety effectiveness and quality
of the pfizer biontech vaccine
in terms of further products vaccines
for covid19 that are coming through
there are two you'll be aware for which
we have
further rolling reviews ongoing and
those will be conducted to the absolute
scientific standards that the public
would expect
so munir do you have anything to add on
this um no no thanks
let's turn are you any indication on the
scales there for
the other vaccine approvals it wouldn't
be possible to predict
today simply that this rigorous process
has started in the way that i've
described
with every package or parcel of data
as it's available being scrutinized and
my guess is sirmener your expert group
is going to be working
probably over christmas to make sure
that we complete our work in the
shortest
possible time thank you
let's turn to tom coulson from business
insider
good morning the health secretary has
said that rolling out a vaccine will be
uh challenging uh because it needs to be
stored at very low temperatures
um do you foresee professor lim
potential challenges in offering the
fisa vaccine
to vulnerable groups who might not be
able to
travel to a vaccination center or whose
gp surgery might not have the
cold storage facilities necessary to
store the vaccine
yes indeed i think every vaccine that
comes
through will probably have its own
characteristics in terms of storage
transport and deliverability so the
visor vaccine in particular has
a strong requirement for very cold
storage
and there are stability issues
potentially that constrain how a vaccine
can be supplied
to different people let's not forget
that
a mass vaccination program s will be
conducted very soon is an unprecedented
thing
it will be the largest vaccination
program in the uk for decades
so there will be all manner of
operational flexibilities that will be
required during the deployment of the
vaccine
it has certainly been a very close
scrutiny
conducted by the expert working group in
terms of the question you have asked
tom so summoner would you like to
highlight the aspects you have been
pouring over sure as part of the
assessment of the vaccine
we look at the quality which includes
the stability
and it does need to be stored at low
temperature at minus 70 degrees
at least but we know that once it's
taken out
it can be stable between two to eight
degrees centigrade
to allow for deployment in the
vaccination sites
and and that information is being
shared with the relevant agencies as nhs
public health uh bodies so that they can
actually sort out
the deployment model and make sure that
the stability of the vaccine is
maintained
it's critically important thank you for
raising this
key issue our next question comes from
jasmine ralston from the health service
journal
good morning good morning thank you
um a few from me the vaccine has been
approved by the mhra with conditions
what
are they how should trust decide which
frontline staff have priority for
vaccination
and how we reassure nhs staff who are
concerned that the vaccine may not be
safe
and finally will nhs staff be allowed to
opt out of having the vaccination
without penalty
thank you the first question relates to
the conditions
which as you can imagine are very strict
and rigorous
mainly around the quality areas that
we've just been exploring
that need to be to the very highest
standards
the second area will be around the
vigilance the monitoring
of all the safety aspects particularly
as professor lim has said
because so many people will want to have
this vaccine
and the third area we will have close
control
over the information that is provided to
healthcare professionals
and to the public so that in having that
very clear
and very precise information everyone
can be confident
the vaccine is going to reach them in
the best possible way
so those are three main areas but
obviously the extent
of the controls of the mhra are very
broad in line with international
guidance
around good laboratory practice good
clinical practice
and good manufacturing practice we will
be watching
very closely that all those requirements
and conditions
are complied with public can be
confident
of that perhaps i can turn to professor
lim
for some of the aspects you've raised
and particularly
as nhs staff will need to have that
confidence
too thank you the
jcbi has advised that there are certain
frontline healthcare and social care
workers who should be
offered higher priority and these are
based around
their own personal risk of coming to
harm or having severe illness from
covert 19
secondly the amount of exposure that
they have
to people who have covet 19 infection
themselves
and thirdly the amount of interaction
they have
with different people who are vulnerable
and might
acquire covet 19. so we have
set out some principles on how to
prioritize
different health care workers and
use those when deployment of the vaccine
is is indicated in terms of whether it
should be voluntary or compulsory
at the moment there is no suggestion
that
the offer vaccination should be
compulsorily taken
up it is always an offer of vaccination
and whether somebody wants to have a
vaccine or not whether they're in the
nhs or not
uh is at the moment a voluntary thing
but jcvi is not a policy-making body
policy is made by ministers
the clear and helpful information that
will be provided
will enable the conversations to go on
on an individual level
so that anyone who has any questions can
have them
clearly and thoroughly answered so many
yes please do maybe i can add something
about safety
the trials had about 40 000 individuals
and half of those received the vaccine
and half received the placebo
from the data that's been provided most
of the adverse effects were
mild and short-lasting usually lasting
for a day or two
similar to the kind of
effects you get after any other vaccine
so that is really important
to note we haven't identified any
serious adverse reactions
throughout the trial program but it is
important to continually
monitor the safety of this and the mhra
has
a very proactive uh vigilance strategy
to be able to monitor the safety
uh pro prominent amongst that is a
yellow card system which anybody can
report on including
members of the public but also the
active recall system that the mhra is
going to launch
which will ask members to be able to
join and and
look at what's happening with the
vaccine and whether they're developing
any kind of
side effects it's all well prepared and
we're ready to roll into action
now i think that completes
all our questions thank you to all the
journalists who've joined this morning
i'll ask my colleagues if you have any
final remarks
professor lim yes i'd like to thank
everybody who has been involved
in helping jcbi come to its advice
i like to stress that we are so far
advised
how the vaccine might be used in the
first phase of the program
we haven't yet decided how the vaccine
might be used in subsequent phases of
the program
and we will be monitoring all the new
emerging data
including data coming out from phase one
of the program
in order to make our further decisions
thank you that's really helpful seminar
any concluding remarks
thank you um i think that uh we are
in the midst of a once in a century
pandemic and think this is a historic
moment the uk is now one step
closer to providing a safe and effective
vaccine to help
in the fight against covet 19. a virus
that has affected each
and every one of us in some way and this
will help to save lives
thank you i would simply like to
conclude by reiterating
that this vaccine produced and developed
by fisa biontech
meets rigorous high standards of safety
of effectiveness and of quality the
public's
safety has always been at the forefront
of our minds safety is our watch word
and it will always continue to be so
thank you we can now conclude this
briefing
well a very sober tone of that briefing
by
the experts responsible for approving
the use of the fisa beyond tech
vaccine in this country uh in case
you're wondering speaking we're dr june
rain she's the chief executive of the
mhra she was chairing the conference the
mhra
is the medicines and healthcare products
regulatory agency the agency
that gave approval also with her were
professor sir munir
pierre muhammad he's the chair of the
commission on human medicine expert
working group
and professor wei shen lim who's the
chair of the government's joint
committee
on vaccination and immunization
the main messages coming out of that was
that
full immunity for those people taking
the fisa vaccine
will come seven days after the second
dose that the priority
in terms of giving out the drug will be
related to
those people who are most at risk
starting with care homes that the risk
of covid uh having serious consequences
is very much
age-related we were told
well let's uh get the analysis now uh of
our science uh correspondent thomas
moore who i have to say thomas we were
expecting you to ask a question
yes uh well the the way that those
questions are divvied out is determined
by the department of health but i think
what we heard there from
the the mhra and the other experts was
that this has been a very sober
assessment which started all the way
back
in june and they've been doing what's
called a rolling review
looking at the data as it came in from
the clinical trials
and that is why even when pfizer
submitted its final batch of data on the
30th of november
they were able to turn this round
extremely quickly the first regulatory
authority around the world to do so
but they say no corners have been cut
and they emphasize that time and time
again they are very aware
that there is this concern of some
people vaccine hesitancy
but they do need people to come forward
what they're saying is that
the company was able to run overlapping
clinical trials to speed up the
development
and then when it data did reach uh the
the mhra
they too were able to streamline their
processes and that is why
we have a decision so quickly on the
first vaccine
against covid thomas i'm just looking
now at the list that's been released of
those who will be offered the
vaccination top priority residents in
care homes
for their older adults and their carers
second
all those 80 years of age and over
and front line health and social care
workers third
the over 75s for
the over 70s
and clinically extremely vulnerable
individuals
five all those over 65
six all individuals aged 16
to 64 years with underlying health
conditions
which put them in higher risk of serious
disease and mortality seven
uh all those 60 years or over eight
all those 55 or over and finally all
those
50 or over thomas looking at the number
of uh doses of the vaccine that the uk
has access to
uh how long do you think it will be
working through that program and
who are going to be uh getting the first
batch of this uh
pfizer beyond tech vaccine
the calculation for the number of people
most at risk is
is around 30 million now we have enough
doses of the fisa vaccine
to immunize 20 million of those of
course we have another
three and a half enough for another
three and a half of the modern vaccine
which is also being reviewed by the mhra
and probably is only a few days behind
so we're making a big dent in the number
of people
who are being who are most at risk of
being uh hospitalized and
dying from from covid now it makes
complete sense to start with
care homes because not only are those
likely to be the eldest
uh they're also in in an institution
where of course
we know from the first and second waves
of this pandemic
the virus can spread extremely rapidly
and that is the reason that
care workers are also being given a
priority because they of course can
spread the virus
from room to room it makes complete
sense there had been some speculation
that perhaps because of the very
specific
low temperatures required by this
vaccine to ensure that it remains active
that it might be kept in hospitals and
that perhaps
healthcare workers would jump the queue
go to the very top so they too
could be protected first but they remain
in the second
batch of people likely to have it but we
did hear
from the the vaccination advisor there
uh professor lim
that it may have to that there will be
some flexibility in these groups now if
there is a problem
locally with the distribution of the
vaccine for whatever reason
local groups will have the authority to
change that
order and make sure the vaccine is being
used as swiftly as possible
thomas i suppose there'll be some uh
controversy
about people who need care who are not
in the elderly group because we have
seen
disproportionately high incidence of
coveted infection and deaths amongst
that group
and yet my reading of this uh is that
they are
quite low down in the priorities list
they're they're at number six
yeah certainly there has been a a debate
over this whether it
if if somebody is a healthy 66
year old should they really uh be given
priority
over somebody who's 59 but has
uh one an underlying health condition
well of course
it is very difficult and they've decided
to to keep this as simple as possible
and just go for age
because they believe that is
overwhelmingly the greatest risk factor
for a serious outcome from covid19 it is
simply about making things
as easy and as straightforward but
you're right at the lower end of the
the age bands there will be some debate
but again
uh gps will still have uh the the
flexibility
if there is a strong personal case for
somebody they believe is most at risk
from
from covet 19 who doesn't uh currently
fit into one of the upper bands for
priority
they will be able to give that vaccine
to them
finally thomas this question was asked
but what's your assessment
we in this country are the first people
to approve the use of this fisa vaccine
ahead of the united states ahead of the
european union
uh is there any risk that we're jumping
the gun
i don't think so because they have been
looking at this data since june they've
been going through it methodically uh
since then
and being ultra cautious i believe that
they
they are uh maintaining the very high
standards they always work to
40 000 people have had this vaccine
there have been no serious
uh side effects they have noted and the
the regulation authority will continue
to monitor this vaccine as it is rolled
out to more people
in case there is something that they
need to be aware of a rare
side effect that hasn't yet cropped up
and there is a well
practiced yellow card reporting system
it's called
it's available to all health workers if
they see any
side effect with any medicine even one
that's been used for many years
that there is a way for them to get that
information back to the regulatory
authorities very swiftly and of course
there will always be this uncertainty
was that side effect due to the vaccine
or simply a random event
but if with this yellow card reporting
system they will be able to spot
trends and that is the important thing
here if they they do
see it that there is something to be
concerned with
they can react extremely swiftly but at
the moment there is no cause for concern
over this vaccine safe
safety we know that it is effective 95